[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la opción de una única
dosis de vacuna contra kobe 19 nos
acompaña el doctor oscar franco
epidemiólogo director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
universidad de berna académico de
harvard y de la universidad erasmus de
rotterdam y asesor científico de france
24 gracias por acompañarnos doctor buen
día para usted y cómo va el desarrollo
de las vacunas
en términos de desarrollo vamos muy bien
y buen día para todos los que nos están
viendo vamos muy bien del desarrollo
tenemos ya 8 vacunas aprobadas es con
autorización parcial 114 en evaluación
en fase clínica y una cientos que están
en evaluación preclínica entonces vamos
muy bien en eso donde no vamos también
es que tenemos que vacunar a millones de
personas
llevamos países en vías de desarrollo
más que todo que aún hay poblaciones de
autor y es lo que necesitan la vacuna
urgentemente y aún no lo ha recibido
entonces tenemos que mejorar en
producción distribución y más equidad en
la distribución de las vacunas sólo por
ponerle un ejemplo en colombia no hemos
llegado ni siquiera el 10% de la
población vacunada y aquí mi siguiente
pregunta que significa hablar de una
única dosis de alguna vacuna hay
farmacéuticas como johnson y johnson
como el spotlight ya la tienen que tan
efectiva y qué tan segura es que efectos
adversos pueden tener
si tener una sola vacuna podría
facilitar la logística y la distribución
y podría llegar a muchas más personas
que requieren la vacunación no tenemos
muchas vacunas de una sola dosis tenemos
la de janssen la disponible también está
la de convivencia que desde cansino vía
un laboratorio chino y luego hay una
vacuna más death in june que es un spray
nasal que está todavía en fase una
evaluación estas vacunas tienen un rasgo
eficacia del 60 70 por ciento y en
términos de efectos adversos se ha visto
que un 10 por ciento de las personas a
las que se aplica la vacuna pueden tener
dolor en el lugar de aplicación pueden
tener fatiga algunos cuentan el fiebre
pueden tener tos y vimos como en mayo
estaban las noticias que se han
detectado 28 casos de trombosis en 9
millones de vacunas aplicadas en los
estados unidos lo que lleva una
suspensión parcial y evaluación de la
los riesgos y beneficios de la vacuna de
janssen y se determinó que se podría
continuar
existe doctor algún estudio que indique
que la aplicación de una sola dosis se
puede afectar más a un grupo poblacional
que a otro por ejemplo por la edad que
tenga
si hemos visto con otras vacunas que las
personas de mayor edad tienden a
responder menos por esos cambios con el
envejecimiento que ocurre en el sistema
inmune sin embargo con las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 no se ha visto
grandes diferencias en los mayores de 60
70 80 o 90 años entonces la respuesta
aparece muy similar y por ahora la
recomendación es aplicarse lo más allá
de la edad va a tener un efecto bastante
positivo para la salud de las personas
ante todo esto que usted nos cuenta es
una buena idea aplicar una sola dosis
en términos de distribución y logística
si lo es ya en términos de protección se
ve que con una segunda dosis es mejor
también hay que tener en cuenta las
nuevas variantes que pueden ocurrir y
también tener en cuenta la duración de
la protección es posible que donde con
dos dosis la duración sea mejor será más
larga y por otro lugar tenemos dentro
del punto de vista práctico es posible
que en un futuro se pidan certificados
de vacunación para poder volar a poder
ingresar a ciertos sitios y si no se
tienen el programa completo de la
vacunación como se está determinado por
la vacuna entonces es posible que no se
tenga ese certificado que podría ayudar
y esa es una discusión que ya se está
dando en europa algunos o por otro lado
han hablado de necesitar incluso una
tercera dosis esto es posible
es muy posible es posible que bajen las
defensas que da la vacuna con el tiempo
y entonces se necesite un refuerzo un
tercer refuerzo y también es posible que
con el tiempo no podemos erradicar el
virus porque es muy difícil erradicar un
virus y es posible que necesitamos
también un cuarto refuerzo un quinto
refuerzo si el virus se queda y es y es
posible que se vuelva común la vacuna
contra la influenza que se tiene que
actualizar cada año sin embargo todo
esto es especulación hasta ahora
bueno doctor y ya para finalizar muy
rápidamente el mensaje para la gente que
aún no cree que es conveniente vacunarse
es muy importante vacunar no solamente
por nosotros mismos sino también por
nuestros seres queridos la vacuna es una
intervención colectiva ayuda a proteger
a la población entonces la mejor manera
de tener cuidado con nuestras personas
que queremos con nuestros amigos y
familiares es vacunar nos así los
podemos proteger
muchas gracias a ustedes nuevamente por
toda la información y nos vemos
próximamente a nuestros televidentes
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]